hemos trabajado un montón de vídeos
sobre escalas logarítmicas y
desafortunadamente este año hemos tenido
notables temblores así que me di a la
tarea de hacer un vídeo sobre la escala
richter la cual es una escala que mide
la magnitud de un temblor y solo para
ser claros aunque nosotros asociamos a
la escala richter como la manera de
medir la intensidad los temblores
actualmente se usa la escala sismológica
de magnitud de momento como la unidad de
medidas de la magnitud de un sismo y
bueno la razón es porque las personas no
crean una diferenciación entre estas dos
escalas es debido a que la escala
sismológica de magnitud de momento está
equilibrada bajo la escala de richter
pero la razón más importante de porque
nosotros nos movimos a la escala
sismológica de magnitud de momento es
que la escala richter tiene su máximo
alrededor de los siete grados este que
tengo aquí a la izquierda es carlos
richter ella falleció sin embargo aquí
tenemos un fragmento de una entrevista
que se le hizo y es muy interesante
porque en este fragmento nos dice cómo
surgió la escala richter dice encuentra
el papel del profesor que aguad a ti de
japón en el cual comparaba grandes
terremotos graficando el movimiento del
suelo contra la distancia
centro así que este profesor japonés
podemos pensar que lo gráfico de esta
manera en este eje tenemos a la
distancia y bueno si tenemos un sismo en
algún lugar tú no siempre está situado
justo en el epicentro cuando miras el
sismo tú puede estar situado por aquí a
una cierta distancia de donde se originó
el sismo entonces él me dio la distancia
el epicentro y en el otro eje pone la
intensidad que se midió en ese lugar así
que obtuvimos un cierto punto por aquí y
bueno podemos suponer que este fue un
sismo de intensidad media y este por
aquí por ejemplo es un sismo de
intensidad baja pues estamos cerca del
epicentro y hay una intensidad pequeña
no olvides que este eje es la magnitud y
por lo tanto que tanto se está moviendo
el suelo y bueno por ejemplo este sería
un sismo muy fuerte porque estamos muy
lejos del epicentro y aún así tenemos
una gran intensidad en fin
entonces reister dijo en la entrevista
intente proceder de una manera similar
para nuestras estaciones sísmicas pero
el rango entre las magnitudes grandes y
las pequeñas tenían una diferencia
inimaginablemente grande es decir que
cuando richter intentó hacer la misma
gráfica que el profesor wahdat y el
encuentro que había sismos
a graficar por aquí pero no importa como
creas tu tu escala en la gráfica tarde o
temprano habrá temblores que queden
fuera de esta escala algunos por acá y
otros por acá o inclusive fuera esta
página entonces él dijo el doctor ven o
guttenberg y por cierto todos ellos
estaban trabajando del caltech cuando
surgió esta idea de esta escala el
doctor ben o guttenberg me hizo una
sugerencia natural de graficar estas
amplitudes de una forma logarítmica yo
estaba de suerte porque la gráfica
logarítmica es un dispositivo del [ __ ]
y bueno no estoy seguro realmente a qué
se refiere con esto de que sea un
dispositivo del [ __ ] pero supongo que
es algo así como que fuera magia pues
sea cual sea la resolución o la escala
que le des ahora estos ejes los puntos
quedarán dentro de esta gráfica y yo
creo que aquí es donde entra lo mágico
cuando decimos que la gráfica está en
una escala logarítmica realmente lo que
estamos haciendo es tomándonos el
logaritmo de la magnitud del sismo
así que si mides el sismo tal vez con un
sismógrafo entonces vas a ver algo como
esto aquí lo tenemos antes del sismo
llega el sismo golpean y después se está
y en el momento medimos la amplitud del
sismo y lo gráfica más lineal entonces
regresamos el problema que tenía el
profesor guardati pero en lugar de eso
gráfica mos el logaritmo de la amplitud
del sismo entonces vamos a obtener una
escala logarítmica y una gráfica
logarítmica para usar una mejor palabra
ahora lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es analizar la implicación que tiene
esta escala en la magnitud de un sismo y
más en especial en algunos sismos que
veremos más adelante así que este que
tengo aquí a la derecha es un sismo que
ocurrió el 23 de agosto en la costa este
de eeuu y bueno no fue un sismo de gran
magnitud éste tuvo 5.8 grados en
definitiva no es un sismo pequeño si
estuviste cerca seguramente lo sentiste
pero no causó daños mayores pero lo
curioso de este sismo es que se presentó
en un lugar donde casi nunca tiembla así
que déjenme bajar hasta acá y poner una
marca en 5.8 así que si tu asiento se
gira muy vigorosamente ya tendrás una
idea de qué se siente estar en el
epicentro de este temblor así que este
fue en el 2011 en la costa este y bueno
vamos a escribirlo quedamos que este
en labor fue en el 2011 en la costa este
y bueno seguramente el temblor más
famoso de eeuu es uno que ocurrió en
loma prieta a cuarenta o cincuenta
millas al sur de san francisco y el daño
que causó a san francisco lo podemos ver
en esta foto que por cierto esta zona ya
fue removida y reconstruida y quedó a
todo dar esta es una foto de una
carretera que destruyó pero ya puedes
darte una idea de lo fuerte que fue para
crear este tipo de daños a tanta
distancia este temblor es uno de los
temblores más conocidos en eeuu y
curiosamente yo vivo muy cerca de aquí
así que me siento muy afortunado de no
haber estado allí en el temblor y de
hecho ni siquiera estaba cerca de esa
área pero bueno dependiendo en qué
escala lo mida este temblor tuvo una
intensidad de 7 grados así que pondremos
por acá 7 grados y usemos un color que
se pueda ver mejor 7 grados loma prieta
en 1869 cerca de san francisco y esto
ocurre un poco antes de la serie mundial
y bueno después en 2011 un evento muy
desafortunado un terremoto en
el terremoto tohoku en el cual podemos
ver aquí arriba voy a subir la pantalla
para que veas el área afectada este
círculo de aquí y bueno realmente el
gran daño que causó este terremoto fue
el tsunami que hizo y los daños que
causó a la planta de energía nuclear de
fukushima y este temblor algunas
personas dicen que fue de 8.9 grados
otras de 9 grados y bueno para
simplicidad vamos a decir que fue de 9
grados así que si aquí tenemos el 7 por
aquí debemos de tener el 8 y por aquí
debemos de tener el 9 y vamos a poner
que en el 2011 hubo un temblor de 9.0
grados richter en japón y bueno el
temblor más grande que se ha registrado
fue en la costa de chile fue el temblor
de chile en 1960 y ese temblor fue de
9.5 grados richter
así que por aquí lo tenemos este fue el
temblor de 1960 de chile y bueno si tú
lo ves como una escala lineal dices ay
no obstante la diferencia que hay entre
el temblor de chile y el temblor de la
costa este de eeuu podrías pensar que
realmente no hay tanta diferencia ni hay
por qué preocuparse tanto sin embargo
recuerda que estamos en la escala
logarítmica y lo que tenemos que hacer
es pensar todo esto en base a las
potencias de 10 para realmente ver la
diferencia que hay de un temblor a otro
vamos a fijarnos en la cantidad de
unidades que hay entre cada uno de ellos
y esa va a ser la potencia a la cual
tendremos que elevar una base de 10 por
ejemplo aquí tenemos la diferencia 1.2
unidades o 1.2 grados pero esto no
quiere decir que el temblor haya sido
1.2 veces más fuerte en loma prieta que
nada costa este de eeuu realmente lo que
quiere decir es que fue 10 elevado a la
1.2 veces más fuerte el temblor de loma
prieta que el de la costa este de
estados unidos y de hecho sería muy
bueno saber cuántos 10 elevado a la 1.2
así que vamos a sacar la calculadora y
vamos a ver cuánto es 10 elevado a la
1.2 es un poco más que 10 elevado a la
primera potencia entonces
a quedar sacamos la calculadora vamos a
entender la 10 elevado a la 1.2 es igual
am 15.84 15.84 veces es más fuerte el
tenedor de loma prieta que el tenedor de
la costa este de eeuu vamos a redondear
lo vamos a decir que es 16 veces 16
veces más fuerte en magnitud es un
temblor que el otro imagínate que estás
sentado viendo este vídeo y de repente
tiembla con una intensidad de 5.8 grados
richter y tu silla se mueve
vigorosamente a una imagínatelo
dieciséis veces más fuerte y por lo
tanto los daños son mucho más grandes en
el temblor de la maleta que en el
temblor de la costa este de eeuu de
hecho yo conocí a una reportera que
estuvo en el temblor de loma prieta en
su patio trasero llegué me decía que los
automóviles estaban saltando de arriba
hacia abajo imagínate la fuerza de ese
temblor
ahora vamos a comparar el temblor de
loma prieta con el temblor de japonés y
te das cuenta pues de que acá hay dos
grados pero recuerda que no
un temblor dos veces más fuerte sino 10
elevado a la 2 más fuerte y 10 elevado a
la 2 es muy fácil de calcularlo es 100
veces es decir que la diferencia en
magnitud que hay del temblor de la ma
prieta al tenedor de japón es 100 veces
el temblor de japón fue 100 veces más
fuerte que el temblor de loma prieta y
si lo comparamos con el temblor de la
costa este de eeuu vamos a decir que es
1600 veces más fuerte que el temblor de
la costa este si en el temblor de loma
prieta se veían a los automóviles
brincar de arriba hacia abajo imagínate
un temblor 100 veces más fuerte y este
terremoto no sólo causó daños además
justo en el momento del temblor hizo que
japón tuviera 13 pies más de ancho
imagínate la fuerza del temblor para
hacer que la forma de la gran isla
cambie y no sólo eso se calcula que fue
tanto de la sacudida de la tierra en el
temblor de japón que se dice que la
tierra se movió del lugar y ahora el día
dura una millonésima de segundo menos de
lo que duraba antes es impresionante
imagínate la fuerza que
este temblor para hacer que cambie o que
se haya modificado el día y bueno si
ahora comparamos esto con el temblor que
hubo en chile en 1960 pues lo que
tendremos que hacer es ver cuál es la
diferencia entre estos dos temblores y
bueno es punto 5 grados pero recuerda
que no es un temblor punto 5 veces más
fuerte sino 10 elevado a la punto 5 y 10
elevado a la punto 5 es lo mismo que 10
elevado a la un médium que es lo mismo
que 10 que sacar la raíz cuadrada de 10
lo cual es un 3.16 22 3.16 veces fue más
fuerte el temblor de chile que el
temblor de japón que causó que el día
fuera una millonésima de segundo más
corto o inclusive que japón se hiciera
13 pies más ancho y si nosotros
quisiéramos comparar este temblor de
chile con el temblor de la costa este
pues tendríamos que multiplicar 1600 por
3.16 lo cual es cercano a 5000 es 5.000
veces de diferencia es la magnitud de un
temblor al otro y ya te puedes imaginar
el problema de richter que dijo como
gráfico estos puntos
la diferencia entre el temblor de chile
y el temblor de la costa este son 5000
puntos y no solo eso porque el temblor
de la costa este fue perceptible pero
todavía antes tenemos 5.8 grados lo que
nos daría más de 5000 veces atrás por lo
tanto no es nada viable graficar esto en
una escala lineal y es por eso que
usamos la escala logarítmica nos
temblores llamada la escala de richter